>>> THE FANTASY FOOTBALL DRAFT
THIS WEEKEND.
AGAIN, GUYS, ADP, WELL INSIDE
THE TOP 100.
NOT TOP EIGHT.
TOP NINE GUYS.
YOU KNOW HOW IT LOOKS.
IT'S ALL LOADED UNTIL WE GET TO
THE SECOND HALF.
THAT'S WHEN CHAMPIONS ARE
DECIDED.
JUST A HANDFUL OF WIDE RECEIVERS
CAN HELP YOUR RTER REGARDLESS
OF FORMAT.
WIDE RECVERS MOST.
A LITTLE HIDDEN UPSIDE THAT I
DON'T THINK IS BEING FULLY BAKED
INTO THEIR ADP.
SO FIRST UP, TYLER BOYD.
BACK TO BACK, 36 FROM THE
CINCINNATI BENGALS.
GOING, OUTSIDE THE TOP 50, EVEN
60 WIDE RECEIVERS SOMETIMES.
HE WOULD BE IN THE WIDE RECEIVER
TWO CONVERSATION IMMEDIATELY
WITH AN INJURY TO EITHER HIGGINS
OR CHASE.
DON'T FORGET ABOUT JOSHUA
PALMER.
WE'LL SEE IF JAYLEN IS GOING IN.
LET'S FACE IT, NOT THE TWO
HEALTHIEST WE'VE SEEN THROUGHGH
THE YEARS.
NOW A CHANCE TO BEAT THE REGULAR
WIDE RECEIVER TWO.
TAKE A LOOK AT KJ.
I LOVE SUN, JERRY, THE THING
ERYBODY IS MISSING WITH TIM
PATRICK BEING OUT OF THE
PICTURE.
WON'T BE FOUR WIDE RECEIVERS
ININ DENVER.
IT WILL BE THREE.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY THE NEXT
TYLER LOCKETT, BUT KJ WITH ALL
THAT DEEP FIELD STRETCHING
SPEED.
DON'T BE SURPRED IF HE'S ON
THE OTHER END OF THE MOON BALLS
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
WITH THE COWBOYS, ALREADY
GETTING THE NICE BOOST FROM
HAVING THEITUATION UP IN THE
AIR.
THE COOPER KUPP FOR JEFFERSON.
WHO CARES?
HE'S JUSTIN JEERSON.
BUT WITH THE RAMS NOW EXPECTING
TH OFFENSE IN MINNESOTA UNDER
THE NEW HEAD COACH, KEVIN
O'CONNELL.
WE DID SEE MORE PERSONNEL.
THREWIDE RECEIVERS AND JUST
SO GOING FROM NOW PART TIME ROLE
TO A FULL TIME R ROLE AND ONCE
AGAIN, AN INJURY TO JUSTIN
JEFFERSON.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, HE'LL BE ON THE
COVER OF MOST OF THOSE WAIVER
WIRES FOLLOWING THAT  UNFORTUNAE
EVENT.
ALSO TAKE A LOOK AT RUSSELL
GATES.
30 MILLION REASONS WHY THEY
SHOULD KEEP HIM PLENTY INVOLVED.
AND AGAIN, PEOP, WIDE RECEIVER
THREES.
MAYBE EVEN THE WIDE RECEIVER
FOUR BEHIND JULIO JONES.
I UNDERSTAND THESE AREN'T THE
PLAYERS WE WANT.
BUT AT THE ADP WITH TOM BRADY
UNDER CENTER.
YES.
RUSSELL IS STILL FIRML IN PLAY.
AND FINALLY, ISAIAH McKENZIE,
ONCE AGAIN, CATCHING PASSES.
WANT THESE WIDE RECEIVER THREES
AND FOURS AND EXPLOSIVE OFFENSE.
SO AGAIN, TYLER BOYD, JOSH
PALMER, K.J.J., JAYLIN, K.J.
OSBORNE, MOORE, KENZIE, A
HANDFUL OF SEPERS I AM LOOKING
TO REALLY TARGET.
FANTASY FOOTBALL ALL SHAPES AND
SIZES AHEAD OF 2022.
BUT GUYS, LET'S GET THIS SHOW
ROLLING.
WELCOME TO BR FANTASY.
I AM YOUR HOST.
MY LOVELY FOCUS, YOU HAVE TO
LOVE THE BR FANTASY FAM AS WELL.
WE'RE HERE FOR A MOCK DRAFT.
WE'LL BE STARTING AT THE 108
SPOT.
THE HALF POINT PPR.
WITH SLEEPER, THIS IS MOCK
DRAFT.
WE'LL HAVE THE CPUs ROLLING.
IT'S NOT PERFECT BUT A GOOD
START FOR YOU THAT DON'T HAVE
YOUR FANTASY DRAFTS DONE JUST
YET.
WE'LL PULL UP THIS STREAM NOW
D GET THINGS STARTED.
AGAIN, SPECIAL THANKS TO THE
LOVELY FOLKS OVER AT SLEEPER.
AT THE 108.
THE ONE THING I'LL STRESS
THROUGHOUT THIS STREAM IS NOT TO
PANIC.
JUST LIKE WILL FERRELL IN OLD
SCHOOL AFTER GOT BURNED TO A
CRISP TRYING TO JUMP THROUGH THE
HOOP.
KEEP YOUR COMPOSURE.
THAT'S THE THING.
YOU CAN DO ANYTHING YOU WANT IN
TERMS OF RUNNING BACKS AND WIDE
RECEIVERS.
LIKE I SAID, THESE TOP THREE,
TOP FOUR ROUNDS.
IT GETS TO A SITUATION WHERE
EVERY TEAM WILL LOOK GREAT.
EVERY TEAM IS PICKING BETWEEN
THE TOP 30, TOP 40 PLAYERS.
IT IS MORE A MATTER OF ONCE YOU
GET TO THE MID LATER ROUNDS,
THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE TO FILL OUT
THE RIGHT ROSTER SPOTS.
JUST LOONG AT THE BOARD RIGHT
NOW.
ALREADY HAD SIX RUNNG BACKS GO
OFF THE BOARD AND COOPER KUPP.
HONESTLY, IF YOU SEE JUSTIN
JEFFERSON ANYWHERE PAST THE 103
PICK.
THAT'S MY GUY.
I KNOW THERE'S CHRISTIAN
McCAFFREY AND JONATHAN TAYLOR.
AFTER McCAFFREREY AND JATHAN
TAYLOR, I WANT JUSTIN JEFFERSON
ON THE SQUAD.
I DID HAVE COOPER KUPP FOR A
DECENT AMOUNT OF THE SUMMER
WITH.
THAT MATTHEW STAFFORD ELBOW
INJURY, HONESTLY THE RAMS ARE
BEING PRETTY UP FRONT ABOUT NOT
KNOWING A TON ABOUT.
ENOUGH TO TAKE ON JUSTIN
JEFFERSON ENGINEER THREE.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY BREAKOUT.
OF COURSE HE'S ALREADY BROKEN
OUT.
ARGUABLY THE BEST START TO A
CAREER AT THE WIDE RECEIVER
POSITION..
ABSOLUTELY STOKED TO GET JUSTIN
JEFFERSON HERE AT THE 108.
APPRECIATE THE CHAT ROLLING IN.
DEFINITELY GOING TO GET TO A
BUNCH OF YOUR SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
LATER.
BUT TALKING GOING T HIGGINS,
GOOD ENGH, WIDE RECEIVER ONONE.
AND THE PPR, ABSOLUTELY, MAN, IF
YOU FIND YOURSELF GETTING THE
RUNNING BACK, IF YOU GO TO SHARP
DRAFT BEST BALL, JUST THE
LEAGS WHERE PEOPLE ARE PUTTING
DO A LOT MORE MONEY AND YOU
CAN EXPECT THEM, HOPEFULLY
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.RE OF WHAT
HE IS GOING REGULARLY AMONG THE
TOP EIGHT, TOP TEN RECEIVERS.
ONCE YOU MOVE OVER TWO LIKE
SLEEPER, ESPN, YAHOO!.
AVAILABLE IN ROUND THREE.
NOW IS LIKE THE KING TIME OF HOT
TAKE SEASON.
I'VE SEEN PEOPLE DO IT.
, I'M NOT GOING THAT FAR.IT.
EITHER WAY, IF WE ARE GOING TO
TARGET A NUMBEBER TWO WIDE
RECEIVER THAT EARLY, IT MIGHT AS
WELL BE SOMEONE AS TALENTED WITH
A QUARTERBACK LIKE JOE BURROWS.
SO PICK 2.03.
NAJI HARRIS, DeANDRE SMITH, SO
TRAVIS KELCE IS ON THE BOARD.
THIS ISN'T A TERRIBLE SPOT TO
TAKE HIM BUT THERE'S STILL THE
UPSIDE WIDE RECEIVERS AND
RUNNING BACKS AVAILABLE.
I'M GOING TO GET A LITTLE
QUIRKY.
I'M GOING WITH STEFOFON DIGGS.
I THINK ALVIN KAMARA IS IN PLAY.
FOR ME, I HAVE JUSTIN JEFFERSON
AS MY OVERALL WIDE RECEIVER ONE.
STEFON DIGGS AS MAY 104.
I'LL SIGH WHAT HAPPENS HERE.
JUST REALLY STARTING WITH TWO
ABSOLUTE BALL WIDE RECEIVERS.
GUYS, PARTICULARLY IN DIGGS'
CASE, GABRIEL DAVIS, ISAIAH
McKEN.
OKAY.
I'M NOT AGAINST THEM.
BUT IF WE LOOK AT DIGGS AS THE
ULTIMATE JUST, I GUESS, BEST
CASE SCENARIO IN BUFFALO, HE CAN
LEGIT HAVE A TARGET TOTAL
STARTING WITH THE TWO BY THE
TIME IT IS ALL OVER WITH.
SO LOOKING AT NOW PICK 38.
AJ BROWN AND JAMES CONNOR ON THE
BOARD.
KYLE PITTS AS WELL
SO THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE I'M
BETWEEN KYLE PITTS AND ACTUALLY
JAMES CONNER HERE.
SO LOOKING AT THE KIND OF
OPTIONS, I'VE GOT TWO WIDE
RECEIVERS.
I'VE GOT TO WONDER WHAT RUNNING
BACKS WILL COME BACK.
THIS IS A TOUGH ONE.
SO I DO THINK IN ROUND THREE, HE
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO BEE
IN 2023 AND SAY, HOW THE HECK
WAS HE SOMEONE WITH LEGIT 130,
140 TARGET POTENTIAL?
HOW IS HE EVEN AVAILABLE IN
ROUND THREE?
WITH THAT SAID, JAMES CONNOR.
HE'S TOO GOOD TO LOSE HER
I'LL LOCK IN JAMES CONNOR.
SO REALLY, WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT JAMES CONNOR CAN BRING TO
THE TABLE.
WHAT HAVEE TALKED ABO ALL
OFF SEASON?
WHO WILL T TAKE THE CHASE EDMON
ROLE.
BEFORE T THEINJURY, HWAS
SOMEONE THAT WAS A LITTLE MORE
OF A TOUCHDOWN ATTENDANT RB 2.
ONCE HE DID GET HURT, JAMES
CONNOR WAS LEGIT RIPPING OFF
GAME WITH A  90% PLUS SNAP RATE.
WHEN I SEE BENJAMIN, THE FORMER
SEVENTHOUND CK.
ANOTHER SIXTH, SEVENTH ROUND
PICK.
AND SOMEONE MAKING THE MINIMUM
IN AIR AFRLT I THINK THE ANSWER
IS JAMES CON OFRL HE'S NOW ONE
OF ONLY 11 RUNNING BACKS MAKING
OVER $20 MILLION PER YEAR.
AND DON'T BE FOOLED.
HE C CATCH THE FOOTBA.
THE INJURY CONCERNS ARE A LITTLE
BITWARRANTED.
BUT GUYS, THIS IS JAMES CONNOR.
HE'S HEALTHY.
THE CARDINALS AGAIN HAVE OVER 20
MILLION REASONS WHY THEY SHOULD
REACH IN AS MUCH AS POSSIB.
AND WE HAVE SEEN THAT FROM OVER
THE YEARS.
SO VERY CONFIDENT IN JAMES
CONNOR IN ROUND THREE.
REALLY DOES HAVE THE WORKLOAD,
MORE SO OF AN RB ONE.
AS I'M INTO ROUND FOUR NOW.
I COULD LOOK AT TAKING A TIGHT
END LIKE GEORGE KITTLE.
I THINK WITH EZEKIEL ELLIOTT
STILL ON THE BOARD HERE.
I STARTED OFF WITH TWO WIDE
RECEIVERS.
ZEKE FOR ME, LOOKING AT THE
VALUE.
27 PLAYER OVERALL.
STILL AVAILABLE HERE, NEXT,
MICHAEL PITTMAN AT 34.
I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND TAKE
ZEKE AT THIS RANGE.
I HAVEN'T GOTTEN A TON OF ZEKE
THIS OFF-SEASON BUT IT COME DOWN
TO, WHAT DOE THINK THE C CLOUBS
DO WITH THIS OFFENSE?
PROBABLY FEED THE BAL TO ZEKE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY EVERY TIME.
SOMEONE DECIDE TO PUT A MAKE R W
ONE IN FRONT OF JERRY JONES'
FACE.
AND HEY, I AGREE THAT TONY IS
BETTER, MAYBE NOT BETTER BUT
HE'S MORE EFFICIENT.
AND HE'S MORE EXPLOSIVE IN THE
YEAR 2022.
I STILL THINK ZEKE IN THE PASS
BLOCKING GAME, AND SOME OF THE
NUANCE ABILITY TO PICK UP FIVE
YARDS.
THINGS THAT MAYBE DON'T
TRANSLATE QUITE AS WELL TO A
HIGHLIGHT REEL.
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THAT.
BUT ZEKE IS STILL SOMEONE
LOOKING AT OVER 300 TOUCHES IN
THE REIGNING NUMBERNE SCORING
OFFENSE.
SO IF YOU WANT TO LOOK AT ZEKE
AND QUESTIONHE OVERALL UPSIDE,
FINE.
I LOOK AT HIM AND I SEE A FOURTH
DOWN VERSION OF NAJI HARRIS.
THAT'S TOO MUCH VOLUME TO BUST
IN FAEGS LA.
SO SHOUT OUT.
MICHAEL PITTMAN OR MICHAHAEL
EVANS.
I'M GOING WITH EVANS.
YES, HE HAS MORE OVERALL IN
COMPETITION IN HIS OFFENSE BUT
WH YOU LOOK AT TOM BRADY
COMING OFF T YEAR WHEN HE LED
IN TOTAL DROPBACKS, EVEN IF HE'S
THE 1 A AND PITTMAN IS NUMBER 1,
WITH THE OVERALL AVAILABLE.
THERE.NS IS SOMEONE WE CAN GET
HOW MANY TIMES DOES HE NEED TO
SCORE TEN PLUS TOUCHDOWNS, GET
OVER A THOUSAND YARDS BEFORE WE
PUT THIS MAN AND THE TRUE TOP
FIVE RECEIVERS WHERE HE BELONGS?
SO THROUGH FOUR ROUNDS, AT
RUNNING BACK, JEFFERSON AND
DYEING AT WIDE RECEIVER.
I GOT A LOT OF VERSATILITY HERE
IN TERMS OF WHAT I'M ABLE TO DO
WITH THE REST OF MY LINEUP.
I'VE SOME ROSTERS THAT START
WITH THREE RUNNING BACKS, SOME
WITH THREE WIDE RECEIVERS.
BEING 2-2 GIVES ME POTENTIAL TO
DO JUST ABOUT ANYTHING.
I'M GOING TO KEEP LOADING UP AT
WIDE RECEIVER.
I'MEDING RUSSELL WILSON'S NUMBER
ONE WIDE RECEIVER.
THIS HAPPENED OUT OF TRAINING
CAMP.
AND WILLLLYES, WITH COURTLAND
SOOT ONLY.
IT WAS DISAPPOINTING TO SEE WHAT
WENT DOWN IN DENVER WEST SAW
TEDDY BRIDGEWATER IN CAROLINA.
THREE TOP 30 WIDE RECEIVERS AND
DJ MOORE, ROBBY ANDERSON AND
CURTIS SAMUEL.
TO REALLY HAVE THE ANSWER TO BE
NO, IN TERMS WHO IS ACTUALLY
GOING OFF HERE.
IN THAT OFFENSE.
MAYBYBE YOUAN SAY TIM PATRICK
BUT COME ON.
WE STILL WEREN'T FEELING GREAT
ABOUT FIRING UP TIM PATRICK.
I AM A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED
ABOUT SUTTON AND JUDY AND THE
OVERALL UP SIDE.
GU LIKE JOHNSON, MIKE WILLIAM,
MICHAEL PITTMAN, ALL THESE WE
RECEIVER TWOS HAVE SOME PROBLEMS
IN THEIR PROFILE.
AT LEAST ONE RED FLAG FOR EVERY
WIDE RECEIVER, GOING AFTER THE
FIRST 10 OR 11.
EVEN SOMEONE LIKE A.J. BROWN.
WE KNOW THEY'RE GREAT BUST THEY
ARE IN SOME OFFENSES WHERE WE
DON'T NEED TO EXACTLY FEEL
FANTASTIABOUOUT.
BUT SUTTON ON THE BOARD, AT THIS
POINT, GUYS, I WILL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE DARREN WALLER AND SECURE MY
TIGHT END SPOT.
SO IF YOU'VE BEEN PAYING
ATTENTION TO SOME OF THE
TRAINING CAMP REPORTS, HE HASN'T
BEEN PRACTICING A TON.
REALLY DOES SEEM MORE AND MORE
LIKELY THAT THAT WAS DUE TO A
CONTRACT DISPUTE.
HES NOW UNDER THE TUTELAGE OF
ROSENHIS, AND HE WILL NOW BE
LOOKING AT POTENTIALLY A FAT
CONTRACT EXTENSION RIGHT BEFORE
THE SEASON.
I BELIEVE IT IS KEVIN NASH,
YOU'VE PROBABLY SEEN THE GIF OF
HIM IN A WHEELCHAIR.
HE HAS THE CAST AND THEN HE
STAN UP AND HE'S PERFECTLY
FINE.
THAT'S HOW I'M ANTICIPATING
DARREN WALLER BEING ONCE WEEK
ONE ROLLS AROUND.
NO.
IT DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME GAUDY
CEILING BECAUSE OF ADAMS AND
HUNT RENFRO, NOW BEING THE TOP
TWO PASS GAME OPTIONS.
JUST THEOVERAL TALALENT PROGRAM
WITH DARREN WALLER.
HE IS ING TO HAVE HIS AGE IN
THE EARLY 30s SOONER RATHEHER TN
LATER.
STILL, TIGHT ENDS WE HAVE SEEN
EXECUTE AT A HIGH LEVEL INTO THE
EARLY STAGES OF THEIR CAREER FAR
BETTER THAN ANY OTHER POSITION
THAN QUARTERBACK.
SO DARREN WALLER IN ROUND SIX.
VERY HAPPY TO SCOOP HIM UP
THERE.
AND SWELL TEAM LEAGUES.
I'M FINE GETTING THEM IN ROUND
FIVE.
JOE BUROW, LOOKING AT
QUARTERBACK AND I REALLY DO
THINK IT IS A TAKER DROP AFTER
THAT.
I DO NOT UNDERSTAND HOW BURROW
IS AHEAD.
WHO WOULD I RATHER TAKE IN MY
REAL LIFE TEAM?
100 TIMES OUT OF 100.
WE'RE NOT DRAFTING A REAL LIVE
TEAM.
IT IS THE CLOSEST THING.
LOOK AT THE PLAYERS THAT WE HYPE
UP.
RUNNING BACKS AND QUARTERBACK
THAT'S CAN RUN THE WALL.
EVERY NOW AND THEN WE GET A
DEEBO SAMUEL, GETTING RUSH
ATTEMPTS.
THESE PLAYERS THAT HAVE TWO
ENTIRELY SEPARATE MEANS OF
GETTING PRODUCTION.
THEY'RE JUST PLAYING LIKE A
DIFFERENT GAME AGAINST SOME OF
THE E STATUTE QUARTERBACKS LIKE
BURROW, LIKE A BRADY.
SO LAMAR JACKSON, THE FIRST TWO
YEARS OF ALLEN'S CAREER.
NOT QUITE A GOOD QUARTERBACK YET
BUT STILL A FANTASY START.
IT REALLY DOESN'T HAVE A
WEAKNESS ACROSS THE ENTIRE
ROSTER.
HERE'S A SITUATION NOW IN THE
DRAFT WHERE I ALREADY GOT MY TWO
RUNNING CKS IN JAMES CONNOR
AND EZEKIEL ELLIOTT.
I'M NOW FULL.
I GOT MY QUARTERBACK, MY TIGHT
END.
LL DROP MY KICKER IN DEFENSE
IN THE LAST TWO ROUNDS WHERE
THEY BELONG.
SO I'LL GO AHEAD AND GET GABRIEL
DAVIS AND HE'S ONE OF THESE GUYS
WHERE I TALKEDD ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE THAT'S WE SEE.
MORE SHARPER LEAGUES IN TERMS OF
THAT ADP.
AND ALSO, LEAGUES THAT ARE MORE
ESPN, YAHOO!  BASED.
NOT SAYING THE HOME LEAGUE ISN'T
SHAR
NOT YING TO INSULT ANYONE OUT
THERE.
BASED ON THE ADPs, YOU LOOK AT
GABRIEL DAVIS AND IT IS COSTING
MORE MONEY TO ENTER.
HE'S REGULARLY GOING OFF THE
BOARD AS A TOP 20, TOP 25 WIDE
RECEIVER.
BEING ABLE TO GET HIM IN THE
EARL STAGES OF ROUND EIGHT.
EVEN IF THIS WAS A 12-MAN DRAFT.
WE'RE STILL TALKING ABOUT A
VALUE IN ROUND SIX, ROUND SEVEN.
ONCE WE GET INTO THE WIDE
REIVER STAGE, I'M REALLY HAPPY
THAT I ALREADY HAVE FOUR PLAYERS
AT THE POSITION.
SO THIS HAS BEEN MY PREFERRED
BILL THROUGH A LOT OF THE
OFFSEASON.N.
TR TO GET TWO RUNNING BACKS IN
THE FIRST TWO ROUNDS.
GETTING UPSIDE TIGHT END WHEN
THEY FALL.
MAYBE IN ROUNDS SIX OR SEVEN
WHEN THEY FALL.
OTHERWISE, LOAD UP AT WIDE
RECEIVER.
I'M GOI BACK TO THE WELL ONE
MORE TIME HERE.
IT'S A PRETTY BIG DROP-OFF AFTER
ELIJAH MARCH AND I WILL GET
THESE RUNNING BACKS TIME TO FALL
TO THIS RANGE AS WELL.
FOR ME, THIS IS ANOTHER BIG EDGE
THAT YOU CAN HAVE.
AND DRAFTS OF ALL SHAPES AND
SIZES WITH THE WAY ADP IS
FALLING.
WE USUALLY DON'T HAVE THESE
RUNNING BACKS AVAILABLE AT THIS
POINT IN DRAFTS THAT HAVE THE
UPSIDE AS THE PLAYERS ON THE
BOARD.
FOR ME, GUYS LIKE CORDERO
PATTERSON, KAREEM HUNT WHO ARE
OFF THE BOARD BUT THEY FIT THE
CRITERIA.
EVEN MALCOLM GORDON.
THESE ARE PLAYERS THAT YOU'RE
NOT ABSOLUTELY THRILLED ABT,
STARTING AS YOUR RB 1.
BUT RB 3, LIKE IT IS IN THIS
ROSTER.
OR EVEN JUST THE RB 4 FLEX TYPE.
EY'RE EXPLOSIVE, PASS CATCHING
OPTIONS WHO ARE ALL ONE INJURY
AWAY FROM REALLY JUST LEAPING
TO THE TOP 12 OF THE POSITION
POTENTIALLY.
SO I'M GOINGNG TO SCOCOOP UP
STEVENSON, SOMEONE REALLY THE
TALK OF THE FANTASY FOOTBALL
INDUSTRY FOR A LOT OF THIS OFF
ASON.
I DIDN'T QUITE SEE IT AT FIRST.
I'LL BE HONEST.
WE'VE SEEN THE FLUG RUNNING
BACKS OVETHE YEARS.
IT IS TYPICALLY WISHFUL
THINKING.
IT IS WHY WE SAY GO AHEAD AND
TAKE THE CHEAPEST GUY AVAILABLE.
BUT IN STEVENSON'S CASE, WE WANT
A RUNNING BACK THAHAT CAN GET TT
PASS ROLL.
THE UPSIDE TAXED, REALLY HASN'T
BEEN THERE.
DAMIEN HARRIS SCORED 15
TOUCHDOWNS LAST YEAR.
HE WAS THE RB 18.
WHAT ABOUT THE BLUNT GAME?
HE WAS THE RB 15 IN PPR POINTS
PER GAME.
I DON'T KNOW WHY ONE RECEPTION,
IN THIS CASE, HALF POINT PPR.
I DON'T THINK IT ADDS UP.
ONE RECEPTION BEING WORTHY OF
AS THE GAME WE PLAY, FOR THAT S.
REASON, THEY'VE BEEN THE BETTER
NEW ENGLAND RUNNING BACKS
TARGET.
SO STEVENSON WITH JAMES WHITE
RETIRED.
WITH MONTGOMERY BANGED UP.
TH TAYLOR AND HARRIS NOW OFF
THE ROSTER.
Y, IT TOOK US QUITE A FEW
THINGS TO GET HERE.
BUT RHAMONDRE SEEN THESON
SHAPING UP.
AND THAT IS THE UPSIDE I'M
LOOKING FOR IN ROUND TEN.
SO AS IT STANDS NOW ON THE
BOARD.
I ALREADY H HAVE FIVE WIDE
RECEIVERS AND THREE RUNNING
BACKS.
SO I'M COMFORTABLE GETTING
ANOTHER RUNNING BACK AT THIS
POINTETWEEN MHAEL CARTER AND
ALEXANDER MADISON.
I'M ACTUALLY GOING WITH DARRELL
HENDERSON HERE.
IF IT WAS FULL PPR, I WOULD LOOK
REALLY LONG AND HARD AT THE
COLTS RUNNING BACK.
NOT ONLY WITH MATT RYAN UNDER
CENTER ALL THE LOVELY THING
FRANK HAS SAID.
MY GOODNESS, BACK IN MARCH THEY
WERE TELLING US TO OUR FANTASY
LEAGUES.
I WASN'T SO MUCH BUYING THAT.
LOOK AT WHAT HE DID IN THE PRE
SEASON.
EVERY SINGLE FIRST TEAM SNAP
ALONGSIDE MATT RYAN.
PHILLIP LINDSEY GOT CUT.
EITHER WAY, I THOUGHT EVEN MORE
SO AS J.D. McKISSIC.
HURT, IT MIGHT NOT CHANGE THAT
MUCH.
NOW IF SOMETHING HAPNS TO
JONATHAN TAYLOR, IT COULD BE A
TOP 15.
MAYBE EVENOP TEN BACK SOONER
RATTED THAN LATER.
SO WITH THAT, LOVE HINES.
I'LL VERY HAPPY TO GET DARRELL
HENDERSON.
I TALKED EARLIER ABOUT CLIFF
ING ONE OF VERY FEW COACHES
WILLING TGIVE THE STARTING
RUNNING BACK A TRUE WORK HORSE,
80, 90%.
SEAN McVEIGH OUT THERE IN L.A.
HAPPY TO GET HENDERSON.
LOOKIN AT MAY ROSTER.
NOW JAMES CONNOR, EZEKIEL
ELLIOTT, AND RHAMONDRE
STEVENSON.
I'M GOING TO GET ONE MORE
GO-AHEAD.
I JUST TALKED UP HINES.
THAT'S KIND OF LAME TO PICK HIM
AFTER THAT.
LET'S GO WITH MICHAEL CARTER
HERE.
THE STARTING RUNNING BACK FOR
THE JETS FOR NOW.
I KNOW REESE HALL WILL GET THERE
EVENTUALLY.
SOMEWHERE, DARRELL HENDERSON.
THESE ARE GAZE WHERE IF YOU
LISTEN TO THE FANTASY
FOOTBALLERS LOVE THEM.
THAT YOU MIKE WRIGHT COINED THIS
TERM.
WAS ASKING TWITTER ONE DAY.
WHAT DO WE CALL THE RUNNING
BACK, OKAY, THEY MIGHT GET 10 TO
15 TARGETS PER WEEK.
SHOUT OUT MIKE WRIGHT.
FLEX WITH BENEFITS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE CALLING THEM.
TERRELL HENDON AND MICHAEL
CARTER.
I THINK THEY FIT THAT BILL.
EVEN IF R REESE HALL WILL
EVENTUALLY BECOME THE STARTER IN
THIS BACK FIELD, STILL A REALLY
GOOD CHANCE HE'LL BE A 1A, 1B
SITUATION.
ALL THE NUMBER THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT.
THE MISSED TACKLE SPORTS PER
CARRY AND THE YARD PER CARRY.
LAST YEAR, WILLIAMS WAS THE
NUMBER ONE RUNNING BACK IN
TACKLES PER TOUCH.
NUMBERTWO, MICHAEL CARTER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
PUTTING IN THAT NORTH CAROLINA
WATER COOLER.
TO GET A DWI LE THAT IN ROUND
12.
I'M FINE GETTING THESE RUNNING
BACKS LATE.
I LOVE THIS RANGE OF POSITION.
I'M FEELING CONTENT AT RUNNING
BACK AND WIDE RECEIVER.
I'M LOOKING AT THE BEST PLAYER.
WHAT ABOUT THE SLEEPER WIDE
RECEIVER I TALKED UP EARLIER?
TYLER BOYD.
WE'VE ACTUALLY GOTTEN A NICE
SAMPLE SIZE OF ABOUT 12 GAMES
WHERE HE'S PLAYED WITHOUT HIGGIN
OR JA'MARR CHASE.
AND OBVIOUSLY, CHASE WASN'T IN
THE NFL DURINING JOE BURROWS
ROOKIE SSON.
WITHOUT HIGGINS ORR JA'MARR
CHASE.
ONCE WE EXTRAPOLATE THAT, HE'S
ON PACE FOR 147 TARGETS.
THIS IS NOT YOUR TYPICAL WIDE
RECEIVER WHERE OKAY, THE NUMBER
TWO GOES DOWN.
OFFENSE DECIDES TO RUN THE BALL
MORE.
WE'VE SEEN TILE PER BOYD BE
LEANED ON.
HE'S MANAGED TO PUT UP THE
PRODUCTION AND HE CONTINUES TO
BE PRICED OH, SO CLOSE TO HIS
FLOOR COMPARED TO THE CEILING.
SO LOVE BEING ABLE TO GET THAT
IN ROUND FREAKING 13 AS OTHER
PEOPLE ARE TAKG DEFENSES AND
KICKERS.
WHICH I NOW NEED TO DO.
SO SOMETIMES I WOULD ADVISE NOT
TAKING KICKERS AND DEFENSES AT
ALL.
YOU CAN TAKE A RUNNING BACK AND
MAYBE THINGS GET FUNKY BY THE
TIME WEEK ONE COMES AROUND.
AND THEALUE WON'T CHANGE MUCH
ON THE KICKER DEFENSE BUT IT
COULD AT R.B.
I WILL SAY OUT OF THIS GROUP OF
DEFENSES, THERE ARE A FEW OF
THEMARGETING THE INDIANAPOLIS
COLTS OR WHO I'LL SETTLE ON
HERE.
FOUR DEFENSES OF SPECIAL TEAMS.
FOUR OF THEM.
I THINK YOU SHOULD BE LOOKING TO
DRAFT IN THE SECOND TO LAST
ROUND OF THE DRAFTS.
THE COLTS, THE BRONCOS, THE
BROWNS AND THE 49ers.
THAT WAS THE FOURTH ONE.
SO EACH OF THESE TEAMS.
I THINK THEY'RE GOOD ENOUGH.
YOU LOOK AT DENVER, EVEN THOUGH
THEY DON'T HAVE VAUGHN MILLER
ANYMORE.
HOPEFULLY A HEALTHIER VERSION
DOWN THERE AS WELL.
WE COULD SEE THAT PASS RUSH
GOING WELL AND START WITH
SEATTLE AND HOUSTON.
HOW COULD YOU NOT LOVE THAT?
THE FIRST TWO WILL  FACING
TREVOR LAWRENCE AND MILL.
THE IN42ERS WILL BE HAVING A
FULLY HEALTHY NICK BOSAA WHICH
IS REALLY TAKING THE DEFENSE
OVER THE TOP IN RECENT YEARS.
ALSO, A NICE SOFT START TO THE
SEASON.
EXCUSE ME.
FOR THEM.
AND THE CLEVELAND BROWNS.
THE ONE DEFENSE THAT WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO GET IN THE FIRST FOUR
WEEKS OF THE YEAR.
NOW, JACOBY BRISSETT UNDER
CENTER.
A LITTLE BIT SHODDY THERE.
SO PART OF MY CONTRACT.
I DON'T TALK ABOUT KICKERS BUT
WE'LL TAKE RODECEIVINGO
BLANKENSHIP.
IT IS KIND OF FUNNY SOMETIMES.
THAT'S ABOUT THE DEPTH OF MY
KICKER EVALUATION.
I KID A LITTLE BIT HERE, GUYS.
BUT THAT IS GOING TO BE THE
SQUAD.
YOU HAVE TO FEEL ABOUT WHEN YOU
CAN MATCH UP THE KICKER TO THE
DEFENSE.
SO TO RECAP.
HALF POINT PPR PICKING OUT OF
THE 108 SPOT.
QUARTERBACK, JALEN HURTS.
YOU DON'T NEED IT IF YOU HAVE
JALEN HURTS.
DON'T FEEL THE NEE TO GET A
SECOND ONE.
RB ONE, RB TWO.
JUSTIN JEFFERSON AND STEFON
DIGGS WITH GABRIEL DAVIS FILLING
OUT THE REST MY STARTING LINEUP.
ALSO, TYLER BOYD.
TIGHTEN, DARRELL WALLER SIMILAR
TO QUARTERBACKS, ONLY ONE TIGHT
END IN THIS NORMAL LEAGUE.
SOME OF THE NICE BENEFITS WE
TALKED ABOUT.
COLTS AND RODRIGO BLANKENSHIP AT
THE KICKER.
GUYS, LET'S CHECK INTO
PERSONALIZED FANTASY ADVICE
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM WHERE IT
IS ALL ABOUT CREATING A PISE
JUST FOR YOU.
NOW, I APPRECIATE YOU GUYS
COMI ALONG.
YING TO ANSWER SOME OF THOSE.
DRAFT IS OVER.
NOW I'M ALL HERE FOR YOU GUYS.
SO NO.
GOING TO GET HURT FOR NO REASON
AT ALL.
I WILLAKE CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY
OVER JONATHAN TAYLOR IN FULL
POINT PPR SCORING.
WHAT IF CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY GETS
HURT?
WHAT IF HE DOESN'T?
FIRST OR LAST, MAYBE YOU ARE IN
A FANTASY LEAGUE WITH THE LAST
PLACE PUMTS WHERE IT CAN GET
MESSY.
SO IN THAT CASE, MINUTE A LITTLE
SAFER BUT GENERALLY I'M GOING
FOR THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
AND NOBODY CAN DO THAT LIKE
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY.
THOUGHTS ON A.J. BROWN.
TELL TALENT IS THERE.
A VERY SIMILAR SITUATION TO TIE
REEK HILL.
THE PROBLEM IS THE CONTINUITY
ISN'T THERE AND TO BE FAIR, THIS
IS AN OFFENSE WITH AJ BROWN.
HE WILL HAVE MORE TARGET
COMPETITION THAN HE'S EVER HAD.
THE BEST WIDE RECEIVER IN PHILLY
AS WELL.
NOW HE'S ALSO PROBABLY STILL IN
A RUN-FIRST OFFENS
THIS TIME, I HAVE A.J. BROWN AS
ME WIDE RECEIVER 12.
LOVE HIM WAY MORE IN ROUND THREE
TH ROUND TWO.
FRO
FROM @JOHN SMOKE.
I THINK YOU CAN HAVE A LONG
ENOUGH DRAFT BASICALLY WHERE
EVERYONE IS IN PLAY.
I THINK GUYS LIKE BARKLEY, THEY
HAVE THE GUYS WE CAN ONLY DREAM
OF NICK C CHUBB HAVING.
DON'T BLAME ME.
FOR KAREEM HUNT, FROM JOHNSON,
ME ON, MAN.
ALSO DEEBO SAMUEL
JUST THE VOLUME CONCERNS.
AND DEEBO IS ONE OF THE MOST
TALENTED PLAYER IN THE LEAGUE
BUT WE'RE PICKING HIM NEXT TO
GUYS LIKIKEIKE EVANS, LIKE A.J.
BROWN.
IT THEY'RE PRETTY GOOD, TOO, AND
I THINK THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO
GET 50 TARGETS MORE E THAN DEAN
DEPENDING ON HOW THE EXPERIMENT
GOES.
I WOULD SAY THAT JOE BURROW AND
JOSH ALLENI LOVE BOTH THOSE
PLAYERS I LOVE EVERY PLAYER.
DON'T HATE THE PLAYER.
BUT JOSH ALLEN, WHEN I CAN GET
GUYS LIKE JAYLEN HURTS.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
QUARTERBACKS.
THEY.
LOOK AT ROUND THREE.
THE RUNNING BACKS, THE WIDE
RECEIVERS.
WE GO STILL GET THIS.
ROUND SIX, THAT'S WHEN WE'RE
KIND OF IN THAT DEAD ZONE.
AND MOST ARE OFF THE BOARD
ANYWAY.
VERSUS SOMEONE LIK TOM BRADY IN
ROUND EIGHT, NINE.
EVEN KIRK COUSINS GOING
LITERALLY 50 PICKS AFTER JOE
BURROW.
I THINK IT  FAR BETTER VALUE.
IS THERE A DRAFT STRATEGY THAT
YOU CAN USE?
I WOULULDSAY, MAURICE, DON'T
PANIC.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT ON THISS
STREAM A FEW TIMES.
IF YOU WANT TO GET A TIGHT END.
OFFICIAL YOU'RE IN ROUND FIVE,
ROUND SIX WITH GEORGE KITTLE,
DON'T IMMEDIATELY TO GO DALTON
SCHULTZ.
DON'T TRY TO FILL A NEED JUS TO
FILL A NEED.
IF YOUR LEAGUE MATES LOOK AT
YOUR ROSTER AND SAY HE'S AN RB 3
AWAY FROM BEING THE CONTENDER,
THAT IS BETTER THAN HAVING THIS
PRETTY MID OVERALL ROSTER.
YOU REACH ON TIGHT END,
QUQUARTERBACJUST TO FILL THINGS
OUT.
SO HAVING DONE PROBABLY ABOUT 6
DRAFTS INCLUDING THIS DRAFT,
NORMALLY, WOULD SAY SUPER HERO
RB IS MY FAVORITE DRAFT
STRATEGY.
GET TWO RUNNING BACKS IN THE TOP
ROUNDS.
THEN WE'RE LOOKING AT FOUR OR
FIVE OVER THE NEXT FEW ROUND.
TIGHT END OR QUARTERBACK IF THEY
THOUGHT.
THERE'S ENOUGH TO KNOW WHETHER
TO WORRY ABOUT IT AND BEING ABLE
TO ACHE THE TIGHT ENDS AVAILABLE
IN ROUNDS EIGHT THROUGH TEN.
PATTERSON, KAREEM HUNT, MBE
EVEN DAMIEN PIERCE.
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE ADP IS
SAYING.
YOU KNOW HOWOW THIS GOES
SOMETIMES.
FROM READ THE ARTICLE.
I HAVE COOK, DIGGS, CONNOR,
PITTMAN, SUTTON WITH T NINTH
PICK WITH M FIRST SIX PICKS.
YAY OR NAY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT TJ HAWKINSON.
IT LOOKS LIKE H HE GOT HIM IN
ROUND FIVE OR SIX OR SO.
WHEN HAWKINSON AND SCHULTZ ARE
GOING OFF THE BOARD, THERE IS A
LOT OF GOOD-UP SIDE WIDE
RECEIVERS THERE.
GABRIELL DAVIS SOMETIME.
I JUST DON'T TTD DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN HAWKINSON AND GODDARD,
HURTS, AND EVEN KNOX IS THAT
GOOD.
I WOULD RATHER GET IT LATER.
FROM PITTMAN OR EVANS, I DO HAVE
MIKE EVANS FOR A BIT.
WHAT A TIME TO BE ALIVE, GUYS.
NOT BECAUSE.
CUTS BUT BECAUSE WE HAVE
EVIDENCE NOW BASED ON THE PRE
SEASON USE THAT DAMIEN PIERCE
WILL BE THE STARTING RUNNING
BACK IN HOUSTON.
I THINK HIS CHANCE OF GETTING
THE FULL WORKLOAD ARE BETTER
THAN SANDERS.
KNOW YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT BOSTON
SCOTT.
WITH DAMIANPIERCE, WE WANT
THREE DOWN EXPLOSIVE RUNNING
BACKS.
HE HAS A CHANCE.
SO SANDERS IS THE MORE EFFICIENT
AYER.
I WILL CHASE THAT BALL WITH
DAMIEN PIERCE.
THE TEXANS WILL BE PLAYING FROM
BEHIND.
IT COULD BE REX BURKHEAD EARLY
ON.
IF 32-YEAR-R-OLD REX BURKHEAD WH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO SEXY REXY, IF
HE'S THE ONLY THING STANDING
BETWEEN YOU, THAT'S A BET I'M
WILLING TO TAKE.
DON'T GET CAUGHT ON DAMIEN
PIERCE.
ROUND THREE, ROUND FOUR,
DEFINITELY NOT THERE.
BUT ROUND SEVEN, ROUND EIGHT FOR
ME, THAT'S A SWEET SPOT WHEN YOU
CAN LOOK AT DAMIEN PIERCE.
ESPECIALLY ON ROSTERS WHERE YOU
ONLY HAVE ONE OR TWO RUNNING
BABACKS.
AND MITCHELL.
WHO AM I TAKING?
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY IN FULL PPR?
SUPER FILM FESTILEX LEAGUE.
GOT TO LOVE THAT.
I WANT  THANK E EVERYONE FOR
TUNING IN.
THIS WAS A FUN MOCK DRAFT.
GOOD LUCK, EVERYONE IN YOUR
FANTASY DRAFTS THIS WEEKEND.
BE A CHAMPION.D TO BE GREAT.
TH